alemayehu está de ese redescubre su
aldea vacía sumida en el silencio y con
el olor a ganado muerto en el aire
encontré los cráneos de tres vacas no
pudieron escapar del refugio su casa se
derrumbó parcialmente durante las
inundaciones que golpearon la región
perdió sus animales y todas sus
posesiones
había apoyos adentro todo se derrumbó
encima de ellos no pudimos salvar nada
nunca habíamos visto que el río aguas se
desbordara así este año es inusual nunca
habíamos visto ríos así en la región
adn de teherán laguna las fuertes
lluvias de verano causaron inundaciones
en la región de afar en el noreste de
etiopía que afectaron a unas 250.000
personas y desplazaron a más de 150.000
alemayehu vive ahora en un campo de
desplazados con sus seis hijos y su
esposa pero no tiene suficientes
materiales para construir un buen
refugio
y aquí es donde dormimos no hay
mosquiteros y hay insectos alrededor de
los arbustos nuestros hijos están
expuestos a la sociedad y enfermedades
de la piel y otras enfermedades
vegetales y de salud la ayuda
humanitaria sigue siendo muy limitada
los residentes han montado muchos
campamentos alrededor de las escuelas
como aquí donde un equipo móvil de salud
atiende a mujeres y niños los médicos
denuncian las condiciones insalubres o
javier lópez a cabo hay escasez de agua
así que beben agua turbia y sucia lo que
causa infecciones de la piel
también está el riesgo de cólera tifus
fiebre tifoidea y otras enfermedades
transmitidas por el agua
casi todas las personas que son
examinadas aquí están desnutridas no es
real y estaba embarazada de nueve meses
cuando tuvo que dejar su pueblo para
refugiarse en esta aula pero los niños
pronto tendrán que volver a clases y se
les ha pedido a las familias desplazadas
que se vayan
no tenemos donde dormir unas personas
pueden dormir bajo un árbol pero es muy
riesgoso para mí somos desplazados ahora
tenemos que irnos pero no tenemos adónde
ir nuestra casa fue destruida
este funcionario local encargado de la
gestión de desastres afirma no estar
equipado para lidiar con la situación a
far fue golpeada por varias catástrofes
en los últimos meses además hay una
guerra en la región fronteriza entre el
gobierno federal y las fuerzas de tigre
no corona y los une corona quién le
niegue lee en nuestro distrito primero
fue el hobbit
luego las inundaciones destruyeron los
terrenos y las aldeas
después vinieron las langostas y
destruyeron las plantaciones en haití
logró subte barco y ahmed amer perdió
cuatro hectáreas de tierra de cultivo el
río se las llevó el resto fueron
devoradas en su mayor parte por la
invasión de langostas que ha azotado el
país durante varios meses
recientemente haro este campo para
plantar nuevas semillas dos hectáreas
siguen intactas pero teme una nueva
invasión
si vuelven intentaremos ahuyentar las
como muy disparos pero no estoy seguro
de que logremos superar la situación de
nuevo fuimos afectados por ambos
problemas las inundaciones de llevar a
nuestras tierras y las langostas se
llevaron nuestros productos
ahmed y sus vecinos tienen pocas
esperanzas para los años venideros
incluso su ganado se ve afectado por la
infestación humana
[Música]
como no tener miedo debido a las
langostas ni siquiera sabemos si vale la
pena cultivar nuestra tierra en el
futuro además las langostas dejan
excrementos debajo de las plantas
nuestros animales se los comen y se
enferman el gobierno y la organización
de las naciones unidas para la
agricultura y la alimentación siguen
tratando de controlar la invasión de
langostas pero los equipos son limitados
y no pueden cubrir todas las zonas
infestadas este agricultor y su hijo
miran con resignación los enjambres de
langostas que devoran sus plantaciones
de sorgo los métodos tradicionales no
han sido suficientes para ahuyentar a
los insectos y las autoridades carecen
de los medios para hacerlo una crisis
alimentaria es cada vez más probable
a menos que dios lo impida creemos que
continuará ya sean inundaciones o
langostas con el cambio climático podría
ocurrir de nuevo el otro año si no se
detiene los problemas se repetirán habrá
escases de alimentos y los ingresos se
reducirán
y las langostas han destruido más de
200.000 hectáreas de tierra de cultivo
desde principios del año una infestación
considerada como la peor en 25 años en
medio del período de cosecha las
langostas y el conflicto en la región
del tigre podrían empeorar la ya grave
situación humanitaria